so we're looking at the distance formula
today the distance formula we looked
before at the idea of a gradient which
is like it's like the slope it's okay
between two legs like how how steep is
it is it a little bit steep or really
steep or is it going is it going down we
looked at that that's great you right
and now we're we get something which
we're quite familiar with like how far
are things apart that's a simple
question that's all the distance formula
is okay now it's really awkward hard to
remember formula but I hope that as I go
through this I'm gonna be able to
convince you that it's actually not that
awkward and if we go through it it'll be
quite easy to him if you know why it is
so let's have a go um you don't need
your calculator for this but I think we
can give me dough if I just gave you
this triangle okay two sides shorter
size five and twelve right what's the
distance along this some line here the
hypotenuse oh good okay so that's
actually let's write this down and then
we'll get a value at the end okay so I
normally would write this a squared plus
B squared C squared and the reason that
is Pythagoras's okay but in this case
what are the little a little B and our
little C well I guess you could call it
called this one a that's one of the
shorter sides you can call this one be
another on the straw side and that would
make this hypotenuse of over C right so
I've got like an A and a B and a C so if
I substitute all of those pieces of
right here's what I look like I begin a
squared that'll be that'll be five
squared which is uh which is 25 and then
plus 12 squared you okay with that now
rather than call this C I'm gonna just
name it by this lengthy it's it's called
a B the distance from A to B that's
that's a okay
so I'm gonna call that a B squared you
happy with that so far
okay now I know you can simplify this I
know you can simplify it but I'm not
gonna do it just yet and you'll see why
in a second what I am gonna do that
is I'm going to do two things I'm gonna
switch these sides because I want to
know what a B is okay so I'm putting
this guy over on this side the other
thing is to get rid of square root sorry
squared I don't want to square it I'm
gonna take the square root of both sides
okay
so watch this so how do you feel with
that does that make sense that all right
what have I done
I've I've well you will in a second but
you don't need to just yet right before
we concentrate on what the number is I
want to see how we get that number okay
all right now are you comfortable with
this idea with the line I've written is
that okay not good okay there's one more
thing I'll add I'm sorry I said that you
asked question a B is this leg for you
it's the hypotenuse from Friday yeah
okay right
so I thank ursus theorem is not just
about the sides of the triangle it's
about the squares of the sides of the
triangle right but what I'm trying to
ask is well how far is it from what's
the distance from A to B I don't want
the square of the distance I just want
the distance right so to get rid of the
square part that's why I take the square
root okay there's one more thing that
I'll add on to the side of you get out -
I have to say this is the reason why is
because actually when you take the
square root do you remember this your
business when we're solving equations
I'll just put this up at the corner if I
gave you this equation x squared equals
25
okay what do you think the answer is is
it numbat you square it it'll give you
20 and the answer is it's fine right but
that's actually only one of the answers
there's two answers there's plus five
there's also negative five do ever this
plus or minus five we looked at this
Wonder Bra anyhow the point is that
there are two solutions but I only want
one of them the positive one where it's
greater than zero
okay and the reason why is because Lynx
lakes have to be positive you don't
measure out a table and say oh this is
about minus minus three meters long
right you just say well it's three
meters long so I only want the plaza
your back all right great we've written
that sit down I want to work out what
these numbers are five squared I
actually just worked that out it's 25
twelve squared will be 144 very good and
then so that's equal to the square root
of hundred 69 and that actually happens
to be a square number it's the square of
13th
so therefore yes I don't and I emphasize
this to you guys all the time but you
shouldn't skip steps sometimes when you
come over and I'm sure you're working
you're like I don't know what's going
wrong I'm part of the reason why things
go wrong and you don't know is because
you haven't written down the steps okay
so this helps you know exactly what's
going on - what's up the birds it's okay
nobody cut anyway so just all right one
very last thing before we leave this
particular question a B is a distance
it's a length right now all lengths or
distances have to have some kind of
units attached to them right because if
you said hey I'm gonna walk 20 that
could be a very short distance or it
could be a very long distance depending
on the units right it's like are you
walking 20 meters or 20 kilometers okay
oh good now since it doesn't say you
should say units that's all okay you
might yeah in the agency I can tell you
right now that there will be a question
where they're looking for you to get the
unit's right okay so just write that
down to help with you